oh the hammer you mean the this one yeah
okay so who's gonna fess up we've got
the inside scoop on all the props
costumes and memorabilia from the thor
sets that the actors who starred in the
film swiped away one item in particular
makes it to the list a few times it's
pretty clear to us what the hottest
ticket item was
and we're not surprised will you be must
be hard for you to see your
ex-girlfriend and your ex hammer hanging
out and getting on so well number one he
loves a good prop
maybe that's why he swiped so many to
say chris hemsworth has taken some mcu
swag would be an understatement thor
without his hammer just doesn't feel
right so no wonder hemsworth makes sure
he has his own stash of hammers kept at
home for when he isn't filming and where
are they kept well he likes to show them
off of course but not everyone in the
household agrees
i put it on the mantelpiece my wife puts
it back in the cupboard the last
confirmed number was five yes
five thor hammers that have left the mcu
set for good it seems but hemsworth
reminded us that there is never just one
hammer on set anyway
it does have some weight to it it was a
sort of the walk and talk one the stunt
one is like foam and soft and hollow
even still his cast mates didn't always
approve of his actions what a dirtbag
number two
he got an epic one
for love and thunder may have marked the
first time christian bale took to the
screen in the mcu
but he didn't waste any time in making
sure a memento from the set made it home
with him and which incredible item did
he get his hands on i have the sword you
know i have that that's pretty good yeah
of all the props to keep we'd say that's
probably one of the best you could get
as much as any marvel fans would want to
admire it bale prefers to keep quiet
about it and doesn't show off his stuff
to just anyone that walks into his home
i don't like my house to be filled with
the film memorabilia so they're in very
quiet corners number three she knew what
was good tessa thompson brings all the
power as valkyrie and has for all her
years in the mcu
and she looks great doing it let's take
a moment to appreciate this epic
valkyrie costume we feel amazing just
watching her in it we can't imagine what
it would actually be like to wear the
suit oh it was a masterpiece
it's so good it's so good when love and
thunder came around thompson had been
part of the marvel team long enough to
know that sometimes things from set get
swiped so when she knew what she wanted
she went for it that is why you can find
some of the valkyrie wardrobe in
thompson's home we wonder how often she
just wears the costume around the house
if it were us it would probably be
always
i think it's cool but it's fun to be
king number four
it was for a good cause
i stole the jacket and some of the
wardrobes not that it totally excuses
stealing a costume piece but this was a
pretty solid reason chris pratt's
star-lord jacket was an integral part of
bringing him into the character but i
put that jacket on and it was about a 40
pound jacket when it's wet pratt felt
the power of the character he was
playing and wanted to use it to do as
much good as he could so his reasoning
for bringing the costume home with him
was that he wanted to go and visit
children in hospitals all decked out as
peter quill i think that's awesome man
that would be that would give me real
meaning for this movie you know if
that's the reason then we're all for the
stealing if you're waiting for somebody
to give you permission
i'm giving you permission number five
hella is here and guess what she's got i
got the hammer
that's right kate blanchett somehow
managed to weasel away from the thor
ragnarok set with thor's hammer in her
hands what we will say is that it seems
like she really revels in having the
prop in her home
so at least she gives it all the love it
deserves couldn't find the ears but i
did find the hammer
number six
like brother like brother
we can't forget about loki the god of
mischief though what's a bit ironic is
the fact that we totally would have
expected hiddleston to be the sneakiest
and stealthiest when it came to taking
props from the set because well he is
the god of mischief but as it turns out
he was one of the most well behaved only
taking
well this
i have this sorry what's that luckily
hiddleston is always eager to give a
refresher loki comes down to visit thor
in the first movie and he's wearing this
scarf as silly as it might seem that
black and gray scarf means a lot to
hiddleston and to be fair it is a little
piece of marvel history loki is worthy
too but we still kind of wish he got to
keep some of those epic crowns
that i knew that that was where it was
going
number seven a frightening but very cool
souvenir now it is alleged that carl
urban has taken a major prop from his
time on the set of thor ragnarok if he
were to take a prop there is no question
which one he'd swipe i would probably
take my axe i think yeah i was pretty
cool
but has anyone checked with the mcu to
see if anyone's seen that axe lately
we've got a pretty strong feeling that
everything might not be as it seems
do we trust this
that allegedly may or may not have
happened may or may not
right
number eight
go big or go home
karen gillen took a real part of her
character home to keep we're talking a
real real part like a body part i know
you got a metal arm but i don't i do too
a clunky memento for sure but can you
say epic we wonder if she's keeping it
to bring to set with her for a future
film she has this real dark side and i
get to explore that which is really cool
do we think she'd come to set with the
arm already in place
maybe it was just for practicality i had
a strong feeling that i was the best
person for the job number nine
yeah he pleads guilty i have a hammer
from just about every film i think maybe
the better name for this character would
be thor god of stealing things from set
here's the thing hemsworth didn't just
stop at hammers he really pushed the
envelope with this one
got sworn breaker just happened to turn
up here
the avengers
while he has gotten away with a whole
lot of prop swiping the marvel execs are
on to him it made very difficult for me
to get another hammer from the next
movie number 10 hawkeye gets what
hawkeye wants alright so this one was
for a pretty good cause so i said fine
if i'm gonna do it i'm gonna do it
dressed as hawkeye when he isn't busy on
set people can find jeremy renner acting
as the valet at his child's school as a
favor so that's why i have the costume i
don't know if they're gonna ask for it
back i probably won't give it back at
this point
number 11 to be fair he's earned them
the famed shake weight that appears on
screen in the mcu lives in taika
waititi's home but to be fair he did
bring it to set from his home in the
first place so he was just taking back
what was his
that said he isn't totally innocent i've
got a lot of the toys for my kids ytt
has publicly confessed to taking more
than his fair share of props from the
light year set i kind of overdid it
number 12. it's chris hemsworth wrapping
us up is thor himself who as we know has
perhaps the stickiest fingers of all the
avengers not only did he bring all those
weapons home
he also managed to sneak away with a
full thor suit he is lucky he's a god
otherwise he might not get away with all
that thievery i'm very thankful for it
and i love having them along for the
ride wowzer these mcu actors have really
gotten away with swiping a lot of stuff
from production honestly we'd probably
want to swipe one of thor's hammers
it does seem like marvel has an endless
supply
what prop would you want to get your
hands on